certain things you can do that can
completely ruin it for you for example
if you're a woman and you have only fans
I'm sorry but I'm not going to take you
seriously that's yours
look understand I'm an average man I'm a
rich guy or anything like that but I can
tell you right now A Millionaire if he's
looking at you and he knows you've got
only fans he's not going to take you
seriously because there's certain things
us man them look for you feel me
I'm curious do any any guys any of you
taking only fans model seriously no no
no I have no but you know what like
don't sit
they do for the money
girl you want to make
um sorry go ahead sorry
go ahead no so personally
I think
you can always argue like like people
would never take them seriously and your
value goes down but it depends what kind
of value you're looking at so like their
financial value goes up their sexual
value goes up no yeah
how does their sexual value go out so I
feel like once people see you've got
only fans there's always going to be
people in public they'll say no I'd
never be with someone from any fans but
check their DMS no most to be there
first yeah but check their DMS and
you'll see something okay I'll give you
an example look look at Lana Rhodes she
can't even keep a man
that's one person from that I know
that's like what one of the most I would
argue one of the most I would argue one
of the most beautiful women I mean I
don't know I don't I'm not a consumer of
your content
but is that part I feel like it changes
across the demographic obvious see
that's someone that we've looked at from
a different one but there's people like
you I'm not sure if any of you have
heard of Ruby Rose someone else yeah but
there's people and people look at her
and still be like that's still enough
yeah
so that's what I said her her sexual
value went up you'd still smash I didn't
say you'd want to be in a relationships
your sexual value but your relationship
like what guy's gonna take you seriously
no but then some people might I think
I mean I can't argue for everyone I mean
wait wait and I mean I I mean
this is Sim culture people are going to
be like oh do you know what your only
fans I see
can I just mention one thing
can I just say real quick like and this
is majority of women that need to
understand this right mandum we have two
separate categories right we have one
category which is for fun and then
there's the one category that is for
seriousness You Feel Me Now understand
when you see all these in-star hosts
sorry can I say host that that insta
hose and all that that who are you know
dressing up in their bikini and all of
that that's us mandum like just enjoying
a woman who is being you know showing
off a body and all of that but that's a
separate category us man them when we
want to take someone seriously we're
looking at different things and that's
not usually the whole things that
majority of women are showing off these
days do you understand there's two
different categories that's the fun
category and the relationship okay what
were you gonna suit her head up first oh
yeah I was just gonna ask like so would
you guys okay so we were talking about
like the millionaire wouldn't take the
only fan seriously and um most people
say like in order to become a
millionaire you have to have at least
six streams of income so would you guys
genuinely in in a relationship or even
like as a married couple would you guys
pass off an opportunity for a stream of
income if your wife was inviting you to
create the only fans content with you
absolutely
[Music]
this is one at a time one at a time okay
go go ahead
um to add to the um women
staying single and lonely after 35
there's a study that says that
women in this generation after they
reach 35 Plus they're going to I think
it's going to be like what half of the
women they're going to be single oh it's
when women actually it's 50 50 you got
to stop you don't have a mic like you
got one more chance we have to go out so
so it's 20 um 50 of women or 45 percent
of women between the ages of 25 and 45
are predicted to be single and childless
so much so that big investors are so
that means out of out of all of us half
of us will be single and childless
um the one right there
um and and basically
um so much so that like places like
Morgan Stanley are investing in things
like wine cat food
and anything that like all the marketing
campaigns are like convincing women that
they could be young forever so any
marketing campaign that's basically
convincing women that like like what is
it ageism like you're beautiful even at
50 it's like come on
come on
listen all right I really don't
understand I'm just gonna sound so
misogynistic right now I'm so sorry
about this but like no no I really don't
understand women these days now it is so
clear
that there's someone I'm not saying it's
the government or Illuminati whatever in
it but there's something going on where
people are just trying to push women
into this industry where you're going to
have to work you're gonna have to be
this boss [ __ ] or whatever and like
understand this the only people that
have changed since 1950 are the women
you feel me that Madeline I'm Gonna Keep
a rule with you right now and ladies on
the panel take this in this game
London really appreciate traditional
things you feel me like no I'm sorry to
bring it to myself but my girl was very
traditional and the reason I am so
faithful to her is because she is
traditional you feel it
comes with submissiveness and all of
that sorry to try again okay okay where
was she okay okay I'm Gonna Let You Go
and then I'm excited to hear what you
have to say and then we'll get to okay
free plants to make okay one know your
your category and where you sit as a
woman we all women all of us are
different we all require different
things we all like different things so
we lack a different type of man
um two you said no we all like the seven
when I say when I say that I mean you
know physicality preference for example
I like black men that's my preference a
lot of women so you don't know I know
but that's a lot of what I'm saying is
we all know the reality is we
um we we all don't like exactly the same
things maybe in in if you want to be
generally we do anyway absolutely don't
make it cool cool second of all I just
wanted to say on the back of what you
said
um and what Paul said can everybody
acknowledge there's less women than men
in the world anyway so that's why I'm
sorry the other way around sorry sorry I
meant to say that we're around yeah so
there's more women than men in the world
anyway so there's going to be more
single women it's going to be that way
because there is less men in um yeah
less men in the world
um if you want to have certain
requirements as a woman you either have
to be of a certain standard yourself and
I mean when I mean standard I mean the
way you carry yourself you know if your
body is what you lead with then that's
men just look at you as a physical
object and they will exploit that
because that's what men do and not all
men but if you're going to advertise
your body that's what men are going to
look at and if you want you know a lot
of women they will do only fans and that
kind of thing and then when they get to
an age where they're no longer relevant
younger girls are coming up better than
them no they're going to change then
they want to turn around and say thank
god oh please you know take me now and
the problem is the problem is with that
when you want them to take you you've
already surpassed your most I don't want
to say it's not about fertile it's not
but you've passed your piece
is natural that's the only thing that's
changed that for us is plastic surgery
makeup
um and so societal standards overall and
it's not everybody but realistically you
have to look at back in the day there
was no Photoshop everyone didn't
couldn't buy makeup everyone couldn't
change their hair every week you know
you had a role to play and if you're not
willing to play your role no matter how
big or small you think it is it adds up
it adds up as many of you know I was
just banned on 10 talk and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible